33 seconds of Disney logo also jerry
bruckheimer logo lives on into the
actual movie discount old-timey Steve's
on national treasure 2 posits the
intriguing question minutes before
killing Abraham Lincoln did John Wilkes
Booth's seek guidance to get a puzzle in
his diary solved by some dude in a bar
will let you decide to reviewer evil is
easily distracted Thomas gates uses this
distraction to tear a page from a diary
instead of you know winning with the
name Thomas gates I see no reason not to
believe you stranger in the balcony
Nicolas Cage isn't trying to break into
a prison to stop ed Harris from killing
millions of San Franciscans in this
movie calling my grandfather alive
genealogical pissing contest my
grandfather told me this story himself I
saw the truth of it is oh well it people
saw the truth of it in his eyes then by
all means well the last movie was
shameless about stealing from Raiders of
the Lost Ark so there's no reason why
the fictional character from that movie
shouldn't be shameless as well also this
is a second Nicolas Cage character we've
tackled in two weeks and somehow he's a
household name in the motorcycle stunt
guy and treasure finding asshole
professions clueless chick has amazing
peripheral vision despite the fact that
no one gives a shit about Riley and his
exploits major chain-store decides to
stock all the copies of his book IRS the
IRS apparently waits until you're at a
bookstore signing to tow away your
Ferrari instead of you know doing it at
your house and without warning - neither
can i but you know abigail probably knew
that the next movie would mean in
ocean's 11 style heist at the beginning
so who are we to argue she still works
at the National Archives after getting
all that money
why isn't she bathing in a mountain of
gold coins right now you obviously knew
she would be out of the house but you
apparently waited a long time to
actually break in because he or she is
like 1 minute later everyone is
addictive Riley I cannot believe you
broke in this is a guy you witness steal
the Declaration of Independence in the
last movie
years no one's gonna remember anyone
involved in the Lincoln assassination
besides booth you mean they don't
already gates lives in a world where 99%
of the people in the world are hardcore
historians who give a shit about anyone
other than booth you've been looking at
this for hours and haven't previously
seen the obvious reddish-brown smudge
you the story about the missing John
Wilkes Booth page repeats itself in the
second column but even worse it breaks
into a completely different article
about high-school students after two
paragraphs this Iran reform article on
the right is pure gibberish never once
mentioning Iran reformer any specific
nouns or pronouns whatsoever and the
same articles first Jew brief sentence
can be found in a random middle
paragraph of the cut-off article above
and this business owners debate curfew
article is similarly gibberish with the
first sentence reading this suggests
that the proposed concept does not
readily tolerate the compatibility
testing I claimed she had this page for
40 years and the FBI would not trouble
themselves with this kind of
investigation that's strange
Benazir Bhutto was a popular search
maybe because she was assassinated in
2007 but this movie came out six days
before her assassination conspiracy this
may be the oddest thing I've ever
noticed in a movie also haha he's
watching news on the MSN homepage Jesus
does Hollywood charge extra for product
placement that is obscenely unrealistic
yes who didn't need an architect to pull
off this assassination since the whole
thing relied on him being so well-known
at the Ford theater is a famous actor I
know the guy even got his mail there
there's only one way to prove it you
have to find the treasure you gotta find
it how does finding the treasure prove
the intentions of a man who burned a
piece of paper grandpa heard anyone else
not buying the idea that the kid in 1865
was Patrick's grandfather even if we
narrow Patrick's aides to John Boyd's
age were still talking a gap of 73 years
which is nearly three generations either
way lucky story told to child is lucky
anything I've just remembered part of
the story I've been leaving out for 70
years they built clues into everything
for some reason she showed up took a
call from Ben and then came back to the
table she did not order this drink and
she does not know what it is just in
case you confused it with Paris Botswana
zoom in enhance technology from a camera
mounted to an RC helicopter no less you
mean you can't just look this up on the
Internet
ship was finally retired queen victoria
had two desks made from its timbers and
apparently the Masons then went straight
into we can make this into a puzzle for
that hidden treasure mode during an
impromptu desk building session these
guys are trained mercenaries as well as
being black market antiquities dealers
Oh what run that back for me again these
guys are trained mercenaries as well as
being black market antiquities dealers
Keith effect is funny single blow to the
head knocks a person out cold cliche
just in case you confused it with London
chilly someone else is after the
treasure then really can't figure out
who might be behind this we have to
hurry that desk we want to miss that
appointment the movie implies that Ben
and Riley go right away to Buckingham
Palace
even though Ben told his dad they have
an appointment with the curator tomorrow
which was obviously bull
I'll be fine except Abigail shows up and
there's no way she could have made the
trip in time unless they really were
going the next day so did he say we need
to hurry and see that desk and then stay
in his hotel room until the next morning
or did they actually go right away
because either scenarios simply
mystery person is addicted toilets you
know who you are you can get all that
electronics through the Buckingham
Palace security post 9/11 and post
London subway bombing my fuckin ass tea
time chips that's racist so then I
immediately dropped everything took the
next flight to London out of DC and came
here as a total surprise not knowing
what the plan was or when you were gonna
be here despite the fact that I hate you
so much that I kicked you out of her
house
turns out they needed to cause a scene
and Abigail comes in handy for that but
what are they planning to do to cause a
scene before they knew she was coming
good afternoon sir hilarious that was
brilliant it was he literally just
blurted out a series of random words he
could easily have done that when I'm
thinking and without the presence of his
wife he's feuding with if I turn out to
be right after I sue them right there
I'm correct skip let me ask you this
question
if the desk was built in 1880 and the
Statue of Liberty replica was built in
1889 how the goddamn piss held as John
Wilkes Booth have a diary in 1865 the
points to any of this this Wikipedia
style page concerning Malcolm give
Ulrika nothing about the admittedly fake
man himself just a description of
Chinese puzzle boxes one honestly you
don't even need to know what the
combination is in order to beat this
desk puzzle because the clicks are so
loud no you'll wait until we're in a
safe place
oh okay weeping my gun out in public now
go the way this parking lot is presented
it's amazing they don't have other cars
parked behind them was this lot built
specifically for this particular action
scene lucky they also rented a car with
the rear view screens for this
completely contrived action scene Plus
product placement healthy car chase has
as of yet attracted exactly zero police
interest
yeah let's steal the slowest possible
vehicle we can shall we first off I
guess it's lucky no other cars ran into
them when they made this wild turn in
traffic second off see this Range Rover
this is Mitch's Range Rover how the hell
did he luck out getting right behind Ben
again third off the Range Rover was
right behind Ben and now it finds itself
in some other movie completely before
getting back into the chase then is so
certain that Riley can hack a traffic
cam and that the camera will have
captured all the details they need on
that plank and assumes that the camera
was working and that they won't need the
plank itself he just throws the thing in
the water
why not it's not like he needed the
physical artifacts in the last movie or
anything
oh wait littering
no but it's our gates obviously threw it
away because of its huge value in
importance
so let's definitely stop chasing it
there were only four survivors reading
I'm gonna go talk to her then plays the
pronoun game and in this instance it's
solely for the sake of the audience
since its dad somehow immediately know
is he's talking about the mom thankfully
everyone in the gates family is fluent
in at least one ancient languages in
marrakesh Jesus skip how we gonna find
that well we won't have to gate so get
it some sloppy seconds guys
take a look at this oh look good event
at the White House that magically makes
your mission possible somehow and
luckily enough Abigail is dating someone
inside the White House amazing what four
people can do if they just apply their
love lives you kid and few movie four
even acting like this kid cares about
history and also memorizes faces he sees
on news programs about history
controversies because President Lincoln
was never accompanied by guards when
attending the theater are you listening
especially on Good Friday this is very
so very wrong also thankfully this bull
goes on for several minutes so I have a
chance to grab a hot dog
Connor allows the descendant of someone
who was recently accused of killing
Abraham Lincoln into the Oval Office
this idiot falls for the Lost earring
I'll check over here bullshit because
the power of boners is stronger chapter
13 instead of just telling them the
information Riley forces them to look it
up in his book and Riley knowing this
without any of these other assholes
knowing is just a lazy way to spread the
exposition around the eagle and the
scroll the secret symbol in the
president's why would the president take
something from the resolute desk and
then stamp a clue inside the desk as to
its whereabouts especially since the
president's book is for presidents only
also who's finding a plank in the desk
and then adding it to a secret book
which by now should just be called a
secret crate if it has such items inside
of it there is a book and because you
stole the Declaration of Independence
for a really good cause in the last
movie and had someone take the fall for
you I'm just gonna confirm this top
secret because I like you why are you
telling me out here cuz inside I'm a
federally
out here I'm talking to you as a friend
Ben oh that still seems wrong
how do you expect to get the president
alone easy blue dress
phallic cigar party trick boom goes the
dynamite I'm gonna kidnap the President
of the United States Ben thinks that
clearing the family name is more
important than any consequence or even
further staining that will arise from
this I'm calling bullshit on these
assholes being able to book all the
possible venues the president's staff
might choose to host his birthday party
discount Randy Tripp oh this much
security in the water and the water is
how Ben and crude assigned to infiltrate
the party and it works are you a tree
attacked as we've been led to believe
treasure hunters are as famous as
Madonna in this world so the risk of
being recognized found out kicked out
and possibly jailed is extremely high
especially since his ancestor was
recently discovered to have assassinated
Lincoln I have known him Andy stone how
do you know we've been buddies for three
minutes and suddenly you've trust any
asshole who brings you a map to an
underground tunnel also despite the
president's protestations I'm pretty
sure the Secret Service guy has to be in
the room with him no matter what I don't
think the president gets to dictate in
this case the book known only to our
presidents it contains all of our
nation's secrets that's close enough for
a roll credits but instead I'm gonna go
with that this is some bullshit right
here after all the Native Americans do
owe us all so it would be the biggest if
you didn't count all that land we took
the book exists why does everyone think
the gates it's cause is so noble to
spill a century's worth of secrets xy2
three up down up down left right left
right BA because the trip from Mount
Vernon will be ridiculously fast tonight
with that madman Jon Voight behind the
wheel a Library of Congress consistently
closes at 5:00 p.m. does this look like
5:00 p.m. it sure doesn't so the
president is just now getting to a road
while Ben had time to drive 20 plus
minutes to the Library of Congress meet
up with his posse and start looking for
are you kidding me
April 1865 Queen Victoria sends by two
coded missives
how does Queen Victoria know where the
fucking treasure is how does someone in
England sympathetic to the Confederacy
work in league with the Masons to create
an over-the-top treasure map and why go
through all this trouble when you want
to help the Confederacy win the SEC
was thought to contain a play first
cipher suggesting contact with la balle
containing clues that won't be relevant
for another 20 years
good luck the South 1880 resolute desk
arrives in Washington sent by Queen to
present news because the Civil War was
still raging fifteen years after it
ended entry by President Coolidge 1924 I
found a plank in secret desk compartment
you know I was just fiddling around and
open the drawers - 1876 for no reason
and found it shrug all this reading and
they could just be taking quick
photographs and get the hell out of here
I sent a picture of the plight to your
cellphone multitasking on a razor flip
phone and of course he can only send the
pictures to his dad since neither Riley
nor Abigail have working phones that can
receive pictures and Mitch is tracking
this one phone this guy who FBI's for a
living doesn't look down at a Galen
Riley get past security with a bull
badge and some fidgety rambling well
this part of the building seems to be
completely unguarded ah during a manhunt
for the guy who kidnapped the president
question is why isn't it already closed
and locked
did they really not have enough cops
were they expecting more reinforcements
don't show me the barricade getting this
far up and then proceeded to wait 10
seconds expecting us to believe this is
as far as they got in that time why are
you even still at the office isn't it
like a lot of clock by now my favorite
exposition by reading aloud there's
virtually no reason to burn this page
because no one else knows about this
page but sure let's do something for
drama here it was a pleasure to burn
over to our movie has time for the riley
humorously Swanson a fly scene what is
this the fucking third grade field trip
of course water makes surfaces darker
Jesus fifty seconds of water pouring it
was like a latch just how Queen Victoria
planned it also this latch way over here
controls a bunch of rocks way over there
and how did this ever work and why does
it still work after 80 years
Riley decides to touch this honestly
whether it's this multi-access booby
trap platform or the rubbery ways they
avoid dining from it over the next few
minutes you can just add a handful of
sins and walk away confident you did
your job well also did the Native
Americans even you school and if they
did that means they had to get people to
go through this every time they needed
to make a withdrawal that's in the Bible
I think actually Jesus or someone said
that thankfully movie keeps making time
for the retirement age divorced couple
humor and by thankfully I mean
frustratingly I guess you could just say
he doesn't know how to continue solving
the puzzle on his own but still bad guy
playing last-minute humor here that's
pretty dumb imago Aram ex machina also
is there no consideration that the idol
may be an important part of solving the
puzzle well it's not like the last movie
didn't have some unbelievable involving
ancient wooden booby traps but still he
survives this Welshman I guess it's not
a national treasure movie if there isn't
some convenient fire based lighting
system I'm getting a weird Indiana Jones
in the Crystal Skull vibe here which is
not only a sign of a terrible conclusion
to come but also kind of extra odd
considering this movie came out before
Crystal Skull who the two geriatric
characters managed to accident
themselves back into the main plot by
stumbling onto the gold city through a
preposterous alternate route so how does
this absolve Thomas gates from
masterminding Lincoln's assassination
again his name is still in the booth
diary with all the conspirators and the
conspirators wanted this treasure and
the treacherous clues were given by
Queen Victoria who was sympathetic to
the Confederacy I'm sorry our great
great
good name it seemed like the only way to
get you in on the hunt you mean you
didn't think that if you gave Ben the
booth diary page he wouldn't have
examined it the guy found the Templar
treasure and you think he's not gonna
want to find another one you found the
City of Gold there's a Matty still
committed a federal crime didn't you
also commit a federal crime by blabbing
about the stupid president's secret book
sir for your information this is the man
who kidnapped for his information as I
recall we were exploring a hidden tunnel
and a door closed
accidentally this man saved my life you
could have just told everybody that in
the first place rather than getting
everyone to go on a manhunt take a look
while Ben's story finally got a real
article tomorrow's news has the exact
same bolt the article is the one from a
few days ago also all interested parties
were in attendance and contributed to
the overall result Joseph Pulitzer and
[Music]
survivor's remorse alone causes been in
the game to give some of the credit to
the flat-out evil villain No so so when
you say so it means right yeah move back
in with me is trumped by the word so off
with this bold argument what if any
other random citizens had seen that
sports car grab the envelope which
contain the keys and driven off with the
car car we're supposed to expect to go
forward actually goes backward cliche
and you also you also insisted on
loading the luggage into the tax payment
system I loaded the luggage yes but now
the travel case the travel cases not
luggage the travel case goes into the
luggage who was in charge of packing the
luggage could not get the travel case
into the so you see the puppy was like
industry in that they were both lost in
the woods and nobody especially the
little boy society new way to find them
mr. Madison what you've just said is one
of the most insanely idiotic things I
have ever heard everyone in this room is
now Dumber for having listened to it
what do you do next
Lauren yes no no don't floor it
sorry no no no don't floor it okay
do you know the expression his name is
mine humming hey phrasing these people
going
Hey
where's the 15,000 it's still my money
if you want a chance to have any part of
his stead you will take my bet that's
one way of looking at it the other is
you get to keep 75% not go to prison for
the rest of your life so how am I gonna
get him alone
I'm gonna steal the Declaration of
Independence sigani associations
Bordeaux really killed JFK